it is useful to make an invertible
function from one that is not invertible
by restricting its domain the graph of f
of x is shown below to which intervals
could we restrict f of x to get an
invertible function
so in order for a a function to be
invertible it's it's inverse
relationship has to be a function as
well what do i mean by that well let's
let's show that this one right over here
is not invertible there's a couple of
ways you could think about it f is
clearly a function it passes the
vertical line test vertical line test
you take a vertical line anywhere on
this graph and it doesn't intersect more
than one time so here it only intersects
once why does that help us think about
whether this is a function well imagine
if it did intersect imagine if the
function was a circle right over here so
imagine if the vertical line did
intersect the function twice like this
well then what would f of 6 be is it 2
or is it negative 2 f of 6 needs to map
to a unique value you need to know what
f 6 is and here you wouldn't know so
that's the vertical line test for
testing whether something is a function
but you could also apply a horizontal
line test to test whether it's inverse
the inverse relationship is a function
or whether this is invertible
one way to think about it is if you swap
the x and y values here the graph of
this function is going to look something
like this
the graph of this function is going to
look something like this so let me see
it's actually not going to look like
that it's going to look
it's going to look like this
it's going to look like
this
let me draw it as neatly as i can
i think you get the idea
so
like that and
and like
that so it's going to look like that if
you were to if you were to take the
inverse relationship if you were to swap
the x and y's
and now this clearly would not pass the
vertical line test
that clearly would not pass the vertical
line test or another way to think about
it is we could just apply a horizontal
line test we could apply a horizontal
line test trying to clean it up a little
bit
to our original function to test whether
it is invertible the horizontal line
test it clearly fails now once again why
does that show that that's not
invertible and actually let me do it on
a value that's easier to even here we
see a horizontal line
is intersecting the function there
there
there and there now why is that a
problem well let's just remind ourselves
what a function and inverse function do
they're just mappings from the the
function is a mapping from the domain to
the range so let's say this is the
domain
and this is the range
this is the range and so our function is
clearly let's just take two of these
values our function takes 2
in the domain and maps it to 2
in the range so the function does that f
2 is 2 we see that right over here
and it takes 6 and it also maps it to 2.
f of 6
f of 6 is also is also equal to 2. now
this is fine for f being a function but
it introduces a problem when we're
trying to take the inverse relationship
the inverse relationship all of a sudden
if i'm trying to set up f inverse should
f inverse what should f inverse of 2 be
equal to should it be equal to 6
so should it be equal to 6 or should it
be equal
or should it be equal to 2. and so this
is the problem when you have multiple
elements in the domain mapping to the
same element in the range that's okay
for being a function but then when
you're trying to find to map from that
element to the range to those multiple
elements of the domain that is no longer
a function this is not invertible so
essentially when we look at the
intervals that we could restrict through
to to get to an invertible function it
essentially would be intervals where
this thing would pass that horizontal
line test where over that interval every
member of that domain that restricted
domain maps to a only a
there's a one-to-one mapping between
each member of that domain and a member
of the and a member of the new
restricted range or potentially
restricted range so let's think about
these these let's think about
these different restricted domains
so if we think about from negative 2 to
so from negative 2 to 2 including
negative 2 and 2. so this is a closed
interval we have brackets actually all
of these are closed intervals notice it
does not pass the horizontal line test
neg f of negative 2 and f of 2 both map
to 2
and so we don't know what f inverse of 2
should be and you could put a horizontal
line right over there makes it very
clear that this is not passing the
horizontal line test so let me clear
this up a little bit
so let's rule out the first interval
now the second one between 0 and 4
0 and 4 once again
not passing the horizontal line test
rule that out negative 8 to 8. well that
doesn't even restrict the domain
relative to what we had before so that's
not going to work
6 to 8. now this is interesting
between 6 and 8
you do have a one-to-one mapping between
elements of the domain and elements of
the range notice between six and eight
it does it does pass it does pass the
horizontal line test so this is a
legitimate restriction of the domain so
if we restricted the domain of the
function to just that it would be
invertible it would be invertible in
fact we could draw its inverse its
inverse would look like this so f of 6
is 2. so f inverse of 2 should be 6.
and f of 8 is 0 so f inverse of 0 should
be 8.
so its inverse will look like this
its inverse would look like this which
is clearly a reflection over the line
y equals x
clearly a reflection over that line you
see it right over here it's a reflection
and this and this this inverse function
is clearly a function it passes the
vertical line test for the same reason
this passes the horizontal line test so
this is really good
so let's see negative 8 to negative 6.
well yeah that's the same thing on the
other side so negative 8 to negative 6.
once again over this interval we do pass
the horizontal line test so that looks
good as well
and then zero to two
from zero to two yeah it let's look like
over that interval we pass the
horizontal line test so that looks good
as well